what is strep a group a Streptococcus
also referred to as strep pain is a
common bacterium lots of Us carry it in
our throats and on our skin and it
doesn't always result in illness however
it can cause a number of infections such
as scarlet fever which can be easily
treated with antibiotics however the
most serious infections can impact the
lungs or bloodstream and in rare cases
can be fatal
[Music]
we are currently seeing High numbers of
scarlet fever cases the first signs can
be flu-like symptoms including a high
temperature a sore throat swollen neck
glands and a rash on the chest and
stomach which makes the skin feel rough
like sandpaper on white skin the rash
looks pink or red on brown and black
skin it might be harder to see a change
in color but you can still feel the rash
and see the raised bumps
strappe is spread by close contact with
an infected person and can be passed on
through coughs and sneezes or from a
wound people can carry the bacteria
without symptoms but the risk of passing
it on is much greater when that person
is unwell
you should contact NHS 111 or your GP if
you suspect your child has scarlet fever
because early treatment of scarlet fever
with antibiotics is important to reduce
the risk of a more serious infection
okay